Whoa!
Oh, I forgot to start the game!
Wait!
Wait, wait, wait, wait...
I forgot to start the game!
Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait!
There is...
Oh, Kairi Dasaiimasu!
Goshunjin Japan!
It's a must!
Hello, hello, hello!
Hi, hi, hi!
We're here to...
to...
Gamble, baby!
We're here to gamble, gamble.
Nice shades.
Thank you.
I thought this is what you would wear in Vegas.
Thought this is what you would wear in Vegas.
So I thought maybe it, uh...
Why are people saying hashtag free Nimi?
Huh?
Is it because of her stream?
I was watching right before this.
Did her stream get taken down again?
I saw like her stream went suspended or something.
I love gambling.
I love putting all my money on the line.
I'm going to win it all.
Oh, speaking of Nimi, I will be on her stream tomorrow for her birthday.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
So, yeah.
Maybe I can, like, raid into that waiting room or something.
So I'll be there tomorrow!
Yeah!
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
But today, we're playing Clover Pit.
I want to gamble.
I forgot to watch Kiwawa's Vod.
But she said that she got really, really far.
So I want to.
I have three job interviews.
Can I get a big old minky?
Good luck from you and the wisps.
Joshua!
Good.
Luck!
I'm enjoying some chicken tenders.
Who said you could sleep this much?
All right.
We're back in it, baby.
We're back in it, baby!
I'm ready.
I'm ready...
To lose it all!
Or...
Well, I guess I was gonna say die trying.
They can't get me, I'm already dead.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
So, what do we have to start with?
So this is my second run, everybody.
This is my...
Oh, we can get another key!
This is my second run.
I forgot, there was a body part in here, but I don't remember what it was.
If this piece is inside, a drawer at the end of any deadline discarded.
What do they mean by that?
It's discarded.
Like, throw it away.
I know what it means, but like...
Why don't I throw it away right now?
Oh, am I kind of big?
Hold on.
Let me shrink my head like a tad.
There we go.
You can basically ignore it.
Okay, okay.
We got our lucky cat, we got our golden treasure, we got our stonks!
Wait, I kind of want to take a lucky cat and the stonks already.
I wish I could do more.
I wish I could get more!
Yeah, I don't want more dirt.
I don't want it.
Rotated hamsa.
Hamsa.
What does it do?
Grand luck plus seven for the last spin of a round.
I can't...
Someone said take it.
I can't even take it.
I don't have three.
But I want the lucky cat.
I don't know which...
Wait.
Whenever three plus patterns trigger during a spin, you earn money, you go to your current address.
I should go...
I hope I get the stonks.
Welcome to the Gumbach Coffin.
Spooky number for spooky month!
Yeah!
What are we chasing today?
We're chasing the thrill, baby!
It doesn't matter!
Win or lose!
I want it all!
I want that... I want that feeling in the pit of my stomach.
I want it there, baby!
Yeah!
Um...
I'm gonna take the stonks, everybody.
I think I will invest in stonks for the first time in my afterlife?
Oh, what a thrill.
I think I will.
Take the stonks.
Yes, yes.
Higher stonks.
Then we'll...
I guess I'll just start.
What's our...
Debt is 75?
Oh, we got this.
We got this.
Let's just...
Oh, yeah, boy.
So far so good.
Oh!
Best way to play this is to blast 777 by silk sonic and start cranking that lever.
We're gambling.
Three!
Bing!
Wait, now I can get...
Now I can get the cat.
Uh.
Nice.
Let's go gambling.
Yeah, you guys can't remember.
How old?
The luckiest ever!
Wait, would that have been...
How do I get a jackpot?
It was my birthday yesterday.
Happy birthday!
Happy birthday to you!
Happy birthday dear Fudge Tart!
Happy birthday!
What
should we aim for?
Why should we go for you guys this time?
Wait, how did I get three spans?
None of that happened.
Where'd those come from?
I'm making money here, please!
Oh, oops!
Oh, I didn't realize, I saw the crown and I was like, what's that mean?
Oopsie.
Oopsie, poopsie.
By the way, the cost to play the slot machine, yeah, yeah, yeah, we know, we know, we know.
We know, we know how this works.
this works.
And if you don't, if this is your first time watching how this works, you'll know how this works.
You'll know, you'll know, you'll know.
Oh, let's see.
We could go for Clovers and Bells.
Or we could go for Diamonds.
I don't know the diamonds.
I don't have a good history with those.
Why do you guys always say in lemons?
Everybody's always telling me to do lemons.
Is there something special about the lemons?
I mean, I do love a good lemon.
I'll eat those whole...
Go jackpot.
Lemons.
They're yummy.
Yeah, they are.
I love lemons.
But I heard they're not good for your teeth.
Maybe that's why I have no teeth right now.
I hate too many lemons.
Sinclair, thank you so much for the tech gifted.
Thank you.
I got one tooth.
Don't be like me.
I hate too many lemons.
You'll end up with one tooth.
Please allow that goo.
Well, one old tooth.
This is what they call them, lemon mine.
It's my birthday!
Happy birthday!
Happy birthday to you!
I don't know, I'm feeling lucky!
I'm gonna go with this one because it says I'm feeling lucky.
You are really Wait, you...
I'm delusional?
Then I don't want to be insane.
If I'm delusional...
Wait, we could get cat food for our cat.
Oh, wait!
Clovers manifest more often.
Wait, this one would be huge with what we just got, no?
Wait, this one's legendary.
All lucky charms triggered by the red button triggered one more time, but I don't have any with the button.
This one is the button.
Hmm.
Clover build, maybe, perhaps.
Increases interest.
Do we want to...
Wait, but decreases by 3% after every round.
I feel like Grandma's purse is probably good to get later, no?
You want the...
Or wait.
It increases the interest, but it doesn't go back down, right?
Or does it...
Wait, but decreases by 3% after every round.
Our interest is not so great.
right now.
It would be better for later.
Yeah, 15%.
Yeah, it would go down, so.
To spam jackpot, you need to get your luck to 15 above your spin.
Each spot on the slot is one.
Wait.
So, like, these have to be 15?
Wait, I don't have anything for the...
Oh, duh.
I just bought the... I'm stupid.
I was like, I don't have anything for the butt.
Okay, let's spin.
Oh.
Oh, my bad.
Oh, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait.
Cancel, cancel, cancel.
Okay.
Okay, okay, okay, okay.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Trigger!
Spin!
Already, already.
Big money.
You know what?
I feel like this needs kind of like that rave music that uh is in buckshot roulette i feel like it needs that a little bit two rounds left thank you
maybe i'll think i'm gonna think on this one the nuclear button because if we do want big old bucks buckaroos if we want the green green the baby green green i love all sorts of I'm a green woman and I love the green baby.
Then maybe we go green.
Oh, well, thank you for the break.
I don't know that once you sit and start gambling, you don't even need to move unless you want to pee.
Anyway, let's download.
Let's download our winnings.
I love green.
Green.
It's the green I see.
In my future, it's the green I get.
Maybe.
Green like this, Supa?
Uh, yeah!
Wait, am I gonna get...
Okay, there we go.
A little bit.
Yahoo!
Okay.
We're starting off a little slow, but that's just how the game goes.
We're just at the very beginning, you know?
I have to be careful not to go over.
Okay.
Ah!
More!
Doggy thanks for the gifted!
Now we gotta trust the process.
Come on, I'm getting so many clovers, but like not in a row.
Did I make any money?
Okay, I was gonna say...
I was about to say...
Can you imagine?
Huge!
Okay, there we go.
There we go.
Okay.
But, do I get this?
Do I get the nuclear?
You know what?
I'm gonna try it.
Why not?
We'll get the button.
Yeah!
I forgot about the 666.
We'll be fine.
We're fine.
Ring, ring, ring, ring.
Double your coins.
Set your...
Oh, it's this one.
Actually, the first one might not be so bad.
The first one might not be so bad.
Make two random lucky charms store free.
Set your ticket.
Oh, wait.
Wait, let's see what we got first.
Let's see what we got first.
We might want to re-roll.
We got the electrician.
What's the battery modifier?
Wait, restoring a symbol with the modifier will restore one charge.
So a random charm triggered by the red button.
Yeah, three is good.
Wait!
Oh, it's a book of shadows.
I got the skull!
Do these do anything?
Do I...
If I create Exodia, does it do anything?
Pick number three.
Three, my lord.
It does?
It does.
If you have the corpse pieces.
Yeah.
I mean, I already got rid of my arm, though.
I feel like...
Oh, wait.
I can't even get the green pepper, though.
No!
No pepper for me.
No pepper, no pepper.
Nope.
You need to have all four drawers to assemble Zodia.
Yeah, I was gonna say Because they They don't go on my desk, right?
I don't display these.
Why don't I Just reach in there for some more parts?
Hmm I don't think I'm optimizing Very well.
Um Yeah, I'll re-roll Because what if I get like these two?
I'll be so sad.
Re-roll.
Diamonds Diamonds Seven.
Coin.
Charity.
I guess it could be worse.
Ugh.
Excuse me, hold on.
Get the coin.
Yeah, I don't think it's...
These are so not good for what I have going on, you know?
Shut up, shut up, shut up.
What's my debt?
Six, six, six.
What build are you going for?
Clover.
Right now.
I honestly don't know enough about the builds in this game, but we kind of got like a stonks clover thing going on.
I feel I feel stonks.
I feel interest is a very a good thing to invest in.
So...
No!
I think I'll...
Okay, what I think I'm going to do is I'm going to grab the coin.
And then I'm going to re-roll.
Why am I always getting the pool, man?
If only one pattern shows during a spin trip, transformed its symbols into the most valued symbol.
Wait!
That could be good.
Because if its value is either of these, that would be good.
Maybe...
Well, would it choose?
Who is good for Clover?
All patterns with non-yellow symbols will trigger an additional time.
Okay, I'm gonna...
Last three deadlines, then discard this charm.
At the end of each deadline, give as many tickets as the deadlines left of this charm.
Huh?
I don't get it.
What would Patrick Bateman do?
That?
Is that psycho?
Wait.
Is that the guy?
Is that psycho?
Yeah?
Okay.
Wait, no.
American psycho.
Wait.
Is that the guy that kills the lady in the shower?
Vivi Kor, thank you for the five gifted!
Dresses up as his mom?
That's just psycho.
That's Norman.
Wait.
That's Norman Bates.
What?
Wait, then who's Patrick?
Who's Patrick Bates?
I'm thinking of Norman Bates.
American Psycho equals Christian Bale.
You guys said Patrick.
Patrick.
Baitman is Christian Bale American Psycho oh it's Baitman what do you think of Huey Lewis and the news what news is this the crusty crap no this is a Patrick Bates Norman Patrick middle name Norman Bates oh my goodness I Tony, thank you so much for the Tony gift and thank you!
What?
Okay, let's try for free and let's hope for the poo.
And maybe...
Maybe painkillers.
Let's hope for... Let's try it.
What do we have to lose?
I mean, I could double my coins, but I think we'll get good coins.
Patrick Starman.
Patrick Bateman played by Ryan Gosling.
Okay, you can't blame me, though, because they're both from a thing called Psycho.
And then, or at least Psycho in the name.
And then their last names are almost the same.
Are you sure?
I already made the decision.
Ah, dang, we didn't get our poo for free.
Dang, that's the one I needed the most.
Uh-oh, I only have one slot left.
Wait a second.
Oh, because this one takes away a slot.
Oh, well.
Why cherry and sell it?
Wait, can I do that?
I don't think I would get so much for it, though.
I don't think I would get three, Bach.
Oh, well, it's fine.
Let's see how this works with it.
If you use the drawer, put the button in the drawer.
How would I...
Oh, oh, put in drawer.
Oh, you guys are thinking with portals.
You guys are thinking with portals.
Oh my gosh!
I do get three.
That's the only thing that makes sense to get eaten, huh?
And then...
Equip.
Ha!
A one!
Wait, let me deposit my money.
Oh, please.
Whoa!
A one!
Two.
Three.
Why did it turn to sebit?
Oh, because that's the most...
Oh, yeah, I see, I see.
Kepia, welcome to Membo Ship.
Ah, good!
Lemon, lemon, lemon.
Um, am I gonna get...
Am I gonna get, um...
Oh, shucks.
Okay, thank you.
I've never done real Pachinko.
Only like a Pachinko that's free at like events you know I think okay what I'm gonna do is I'm not gonna press the button and I'm gonna let these charge together you know what I mean I'm scared of doing pachinko I'm gonna I'm scared
change the lemon
That would have been crazy.
Am I gonna make it?
Am I gonna die?
I'm not getting anything.
Honestly, this is kind of terrible.
Wait, the painkillers are terrible right now.
Well, not terrible, but...
You know what I mean.
Oh, shucks.
I think I might have to...
Uh...
Press the button.
Painkillers really, they're keeping you alive.
Yeah.
Like, they're good, but they're not what I want them to do because I need more...
I need more power on my Clover.
Ha!
We just need one good round.
One, but a good one.
This is pretty bad.
I might be dead.
I might be done so right now.
If your knight is reliant on painkillers and poo, I promise it's not a good time.
Um...
Yeah, I think we're in desperate times.
I need to push the button.
It's desperate times!
It's double, too.
So this might actually be good.
Oh, come on.
Oh!
Okay!
This will...
Yeah!
Okay!
Woo!
This is...
This is the...
This is the gamble, baby.
Oh, okay, nice.
One spin left.
That might have saved me.
That might have been what saved me!
Oh my god!
Yeah, I have enough!
We may or may not need the Takanashi Kiara build.
No, everybody can't do the same build all the time, you guys.
That's boring.
Boring, boring.
Wait, what was I doing?
Oh, yeah, yeah, we're good.
Barely.
Holy cow!
I'm putting it all on green.
Oh, we're so screwed.
Oh, I could double the value of clovers and bells.
What's the...
Oh, every last pattern triggers one more time.
I think we're feeling lucky.
What do we got here going on?
We got some red peppers.
We got some clickers.
We got some irons.
We got some horseshoe.
Choose Charms with trigger randomly activate double more.
I think we just got it.
I can't.
Neither of them are charged.
This is so bad.
But look at that now.
Maybe it's okay.
Yeah.
Do we need the poop jar?
Oh!
Three.
It didn't even come up!
The pills will work now.
Yeah, exactly.
Let's go gambling.
Oh, geez.
This is so bad.
Guys, I don't think we're gonna make it.
Guys.
This might be a bust.
All we need is one.
One but a good one.
I think I'll be able to do the poop on the last spin.
Let's go, carefully.
Hi!
Terry!
Terry, Terry boy!
Terry, Terry girl!
This is quite bleak.
Guys, this is pretty bleak.
I think we're cooked.
Guys!
Hey!
My things are not aligning at all, which is what's really bad.
It's my fault, I guess, but...
Next spin is a... 10,000?
Oh!
See, that would have been really great if it was a lot more close.
Oh, please!
Oh,
I got an extra spin!
Uh-oh.
Are you bad at me?
Ah!
Let me have the buddy at least!
I'll die with it!
Sad.
How did I get so lucky the first time, huh, I wonder?
I had such a good first run.
This next one is hot dog, I swear.
Again, again, again!
Oh, we got something new.
What's that, though?
When you are about to die, you get two extra rounds.
Then discard this charm.
I see, I could have used that.
I could have used that.
I could've...
I could've.
I could...
Yeah!
I think maybe.
We'll just grab the coin for now.
But is this one of lucky time triggers during a spin?
Or is this bonus by one?
Oh yeah, that's right.
Thank you, thank you!
Rip me into wait You can still say that I you can still wish for me to rest in peace I mean I'm not Because I'm here I'm not Because I'm dead but It's still nice to you know Wish for that and for ghosts I'm a restless spirit But you know I need more luck I need more luck Maybe we will get the hamster Maybe we will get it Let's go gambling Let's go gambling
Maybe I will go with lemon Lemon is kind of like I like to collect things I have lemons on them you know What's the salt for?
Huh?
Oh Lemon, lemon, lemon.
I think I made $1.
I think I made, like, no money.
So sad.
Can I even, actually, can I even get this?
Will I be able to get three?
I guess.
Maybe not.
I think this is the sign.
This is the sign that I need to go.
I'm so full lemon!
Maybe you guys were right.
Maybe I should have... Maybe I wasn't getting one guide.
Maybe.
Oh, more lemons!
More lemons!
Lemon maxing?
Oh,
I can get this.
I'm gonna try it.
I want to be lucky.
I want to be lucky!
Please!
Hey!
I got lemons again!
And more lemons!
Why?
Thanks for the lemon, Murphy.
Boop, boop!
Oh, nice.
Lemons are only worth two, but I guess because there's so many, huh?
Lemon!
Sorry for Club Iron Mouse?
I'm excited!
I am!
I'm so excited!
Thank you, thank you!
Cha-ching!
So I go, thank you so much for the fun!
Thank you!
Lemons?
Gold and diamonds are a good investment.
Double the value of diamonds and treasures.
At the ambitious trait, patterns multiplier plus one to a random lucky charm you have equipped.
And the ore I could get 5...
5.
When life gives you lemons, you re-spin.
Let's see, hold on real quick, what we have here as well.
D4 re-rolls all symbols that are not inside a pattern during the current spin.
Ah, I see I see.
Ten, ten, ten, ten, ten, go, go, go, go, go, go!
Thank you!
I don't want to...
I don't think I need to really spend here, so maybe I re-roll.
D4 is good.
I guess it always helps guarantee that you...
Or not, it's not always, but it guarantees that you will then get money.
But I would have to not re-roll, I would have to get the green, the green...
How much is it?
Three?
I'll be able to get it at the end, no?
Yeah, let's re-roll this.
And then...
I'll just play.
Oh.
Do we become a cherry boy instead?
But lemons, it was like prophesied to me, I feel.
I've been getting so many lemons.
Increase the value of patterns with three or less symbols by their base value.
Fruit run?
Wait, but then I should have gotten the cherry earlier.
I do like cherries.
Do you?
Oh, wait!
I do have cherries.
Oh, I do say...
Oh, but I can only get one or the other.
Let's go for now.
Look at this!
This just feels like it's meant for me.
Lemons.
Oh, thank God.
Something.
Guys, this is not...
Oh, just a little.
Oh, one more!
Thank you!
So kind!
What is this lock?
Oh, you must be new here.
Welcome to Mint Phantom Channel, where I love gambling, and I also am an extremely unlucky ghost.
Thank you!
That's the part of the thrill!
Is when I hit them highs!
Which I don't do often.
I sure hit them.
Sometimes.
I've become a wist just before your 3D debut.
Thank you!
Thank you so much!
So, welcome!
How can this cute and small body create such a powerful, wonderful voice?
I love your clear laugh as well.
Thanks.
Thank you.
Who's kissing the cherry poll?
Polaroid!
Gambling loves you too.
It's me, I'm kissing it.
Hi, these cherries are They're betraying me!
I wish the coin would trigger on the final spin.
Oh!
Like that!
And then I do...
With no... With no multipliers!
I got my first jackpot!
You, you, you!
Well, I guess that is a multiplier, huh?
But you know what I mean!
I told you The lows are low, but the highs are highs, baby Wait Is this my last turn or Can I Oh yes, I can spin again Right?
One more round Okay, okay
I'm still deciding Oh, I singly trace, thank you Let's go!
For anyone playing at home, let's finish your drink.
What are you, what are you playing?
Well, this one has a higher rarity, so maybe I get the D4, huh?
Maybe I get the D4.
Let's go get it.
It's so beautiful!
Yeah!
I think they'll get the D4.
I think so.
Yeah, 30% isn't bad.
You're right, you're right, you're right.
Free spin!
What are my cherries looking at?
Oh, actually, that's okay, you know.
Oh, that scared me.
I didn't realize.
Oh!
Lucky hand, lucky hand!
Wait, this is kind of awesome.
Wait, this combo is kind of crazy.
Wait.
It's kind of great.
Peep.
I'll be back for you, little cherry.
I'll be back for you, my sweet.
Yes.
Have some peace.
It doubles your clover tickets, it sets your coins to zero.
Make random lucky charms in the store free.
Well, what we have?
What we got?
Doesn't take space.
Immediately earn 30% of the debt amount.
Oh, wait.
Oh, but I can't buy.
I have nothing.
Wait, one is good.
Oh, because we're trying to get more cherries, right?
Oh.
And or lemons.
Yeah, less of those means more cherries, exactly.
We'll go with it.
Thank you guys for helping me out.
Thank you.
Thank you, thank you, thank you.
All right.
I only have a couple things.
We'll see how the...
What does this do again?
Oh, yes, yes.
We'll see how our D24...
Whoa, that like crazy took them out.
Wow.
Okay, okay, okay, okay.
I need to raise my cherry amount though.
We need to get more.
I can't afford anything though.
Let's go carefully.
Wait!
Whoa.
Whoa!
Whoa, it's triggered immediately.
Big cherry!
Like, right now, I'm getting stuff ish, but like the amount is so low, it's like, you know?
Lemon, lemon, lemon, lemon, lemon, lemon!
Yeah, the value is low, but that's why you like kind of, they show up more though, you know?
Lemon, lemon, lemon, lemon.
That's crazy because lemons show up so much, but I have the higher multiplier or higher percentage on cherries.
It's so strange.
Okay.
See, look at this!
How?
No, I think it's... I think lemons is cheating!
Oh, that was scary.
I think it's...
Whoa!
Sorry.
Oh my gosh, so close.
I need to take a sip before that.
Come on, baby!
And...
Lucky spin?
Mkai.
Thanks for the drinks, you guys.
Thank you.
Alright.
Wait.
I'm not quite there yet.
Not quite there yet.
Yeah.
Let's just keep going.
I know the payouts are so small.
It's kind of...
painful right now.
I think next round it's really gonna hurt us.
Unless we can do some.
Unless we give something.
Briefcase doesn't mean you're safe.
Oh, true.
True, true, true, true.
But...
We'll see.
Because...
Yeah.
Oh, we need scaling.
Oh, we're getting more spins though, this is kind of awesome.
Everything's just so small, everything, look, we're six, that's nothing.
Need that golden cherry.
All right, lucky spin!
Ah, so close!
Dusty dog, thank you so much for the time!
Thank you!
Okay.
So stinking close.
Because immediately earned 30% of the debt amount.
I don't think it's worth spending the two tickets on it, you know?
Oh, we're so screwed.
Charm space by one permanently.
Add the ambitious trait.
Patterns multiplier plus one to random lucky charm.
Okay, let's see what we got.
Plus one option is at the telephone.
Wait, during every spin, increase all symbols by their base value for every pattern triggered after the second one.
That'll...
Mushroom is good?
I don't really understand it though.
Explain it to me like I'm a baby.
What I could do It keeps adding points per roll scored Oh
Big numbers I like big numbers What I'm thinking though Okay hold on If I do the diary And then I go back to the phone I could get an extra option And then after the next round I could get the mushrooms Okay
Oh wait, but this stays over here, doesn't it?
Treasures.
I think what I'm going to do is I'm going to grab this.
Plus one charm slot is really good.
I need to start multiplying my...
That's why I want to...
I can get it next round.
Will I have enough money?
You know?
I'm going to get the mushroom.
We can maybe get this again someday.
Okay.
Oh, wait.
Okay, shoo!
Let's go gambling!
Yeah, we need to not die!
Okay.
How do I know what the mushroom is doing?
Alright, mushroom!
For charms!
What did it do?
Check cherry.
Oh!
So many clover.
It's not bad though.
It's worth a good amount.
It resets every round.
Okay, okay, okay.
Another hodou?
I see, I see.
I don't know though, guys.
It's still not a lot.
It's still not a lot that we're reaping in, you know?
I don't think we're gonna make it.
Let's go get ready.
Oh, we're not gonna.
gonna make it.
We're not gonna make it!
This is so bad.
We're not gonna make it.
I think
since I'm not gonna make it we just re-roll and see what we get maybe
the pepper pepper might work yeah
where do you see what my luck is or is this the no this is the money wait where do you see what the luck is because I see sometimes you guys are like oh if you have 15 luck you guarantee It's jackpot.
Oh, it's hidden.
Oh, okay, okay.
I was gonna say.
How do you guys know then?
Should I reroll again?
I really, I'm like...
It will, like, basically half my amount over, but...
Uh...
More clovers?
We get free money?
All abilities that you pick on the telephone trigger one more time.
Uh...
Labid!
Wait!
I could get the briefcase.
Let's do a free money.
And...
Immediately earn 30% of the dead amount.
I guess...
Yeah.
I could use that.
I could definitely use that.
get the lemon but like lemon I don't know
I don't think so I don't know I don't know
I'm gonna die if I die I die I guess you know whatever let's go gambling
all of that all of that for what
okay more lemons please trying to look over okay see there I just want to see them out
okay as long as we keep getting spins from the coin it's not so bad I suppose.
Okay.
What are you doing anyway, huh?
Are you even helping?
Are you even helping right now?
Cherries are like...
Ah, it's all us, baby.
Ah!
That was insane!
Never back down, never won!
Oh my god!
Oh, we're...
I don't know about this one, guys.
Wait, what?
All of these are...
None of these are...
Okay, but she's hooked.
When life gives you lemons, make money.
Four is good, this one.
Here's the value of patterns with four plus symbols by their base value.
Okay.
Pattern one.
There's the other pattern.
I don't know.
I found a winning strategy!
Oh my gosh, wait!
How do they have that emoji?
Wait!
When you're about to die, you get the two extra rounds!
Lucky cat!
And we could get the 30%!
Wait.
What is it?
What am I at?
Well, I'm at 7 out of 7, you lies.
I think I'll sell the book.
I think I'll sell the book...
And then we can get the briefcase and the cat.
Store it?
I guess that's... Well, oh, I only get one back for it.
Wait, how much was it?
Three.
Oh, I can.
I don't have to sell it at all.
Just kidding.
She's not gonna make it!
She bought it!
that references my all-time it's not even my favorite ride okay there's this okay you guys i think i've talked about this on i'm almost positive i talked about this on stream before the the dinosaur ride uh animal kingdom and oh i have okay we'll watch it later i'll show you guys i'll show you guys like a little i watch this like uh pov of riding the ride every like every now and then but at the end of the ride it's so funny because like okay so the ride is you are going back in time to um to dinosaur era to get an iguanodon i don't know reason they teleport you back in time to like to like two minutes before the meteor hits because you know whatever the the thrill of it all i suppose and so um and so uh uh you are riding through and you're you're looking at the dinosaur and you're just like no not that dino that not that dino and then and then the meteor starts coming in they're just like oh gosh oh don't worry about it these are just tiny meteors you'll be fine just dodge them okay
and then you finally find the iguanodon and he's like no just leave it you're we gotta get you back and then at the very end of the ride he goes they're not gonna make it they're not gonna make it
it's so funny down the ride for Indiana Jones and I'm so sad I'm gonna try and make time to go on it one last time I've only been on it like once but I remember it so vividly even before even before like watching the POV of it I remember it so vividly anyway what was I doing oh I was putting you in the drawer and then we're gonna buy you and buy you money money money
Okay, now we have a decent interest.
500, not bad.
Thank you, Cat.
Thank you.
And I think we can start.
Great save on the ride.
I, oh my gosh, I can't believe we actually lived.
I can't believe it.
This could be better.
Oh, thank you.
Lemon, lemon, lemon, lemon, lemon.
The U.S.
Mint got nothing on...
Made men.
What's the U.S.
men?
Wham!
I like the sound the 666 makes.
Okay, this is not good.
I could be really lucky right now!
Uh...
Oh!
That wasn't so bad at the end.
I suppose?
Boop, boop, boop, boop, boop, boop.
Cat carry.
Honestly, cat is so good.
I feel like he is for every run.
I wish my lemon would recharge, though.
Almost!
Oh my gosh.
Let's go.
Cherry, cherry, cherry.
Yeah!
Cherry.
I can't...
Oh, thank goodness.
We got another spin.
Please, please!
Oh!
Cat is OP.
Yeah, for real.
I don't know, though.
Maybe.
If we...
I keep thinking the dark mass to the left of the machine is a person.
This?
Oh, I see it.
I see, like, the head and the shoulders here.
Oh, freaky!
Creepy!
I don't have room for the yonk.
I don't have room for it.
My D... whatever.
D4 has not gone off in a bit.
Oh wait, yes it has.
I'm sorry.
I forgot what it did.
Sell lemon?
I guess we could.
Just in case, have this.
Just in case.
Hmm.
Check the pepper.
What about it?
4 activate.
Oh, I forgot that we have to get rid of it after a certain amount of time.
No, no, no!
No!
I think I'll get the Ankh just in.
Okay.
Oh yeah, it would work well with this too, huh?
Because we get the extra rounds.
Juicy.
Whoa, it's glowing.
Let's go gambling.
Hoi!
Oh, come on.
Seriously?
Okay, it's a good thing we bought it.
It's a good thing we bought it!
Oh my gosh It's a good thing we bought it It's a really good thing we bought it Oh it's a good thing we bought it Oh my gosh it's a good thing we bought it
What no I have more Wait no no way to have it Use use use use Wait how do I use it
Oh okay I uses it Well well well Looks like I'm obliged to give you those extra rounds.
Mere death experience survive.
Oh, nice.
Oh my gosh.
Look, we were so close even, too.
That's kind of messed up.
Okay.
What I'm going to do is I'm going to take...
It doesn't really do anything, but I'm going to equip it so that we can at least get the...
extra things.
Holy cow!
Cherry,
cherry, cherry, cherry, cherry, cherry, cherry, oh!
We made it!
Where were you?
Where was this luck before, huh?
But it's fine because we get the two extra rounds, so we'll get some extra money.
Okay.
Yeah, a little bit of a head start, exactly, exactly.
Oh, nice!
My pepper.
That was a good amount.
That was a good amount, everybody.
Oh, I want to deposit it for the extra interest, but I will refrain since we paid for this extra round.
So I will...
Yeah.
We paid for it.
Let's go gambling.
Yeah, we'll also get two extra tickets.
Whoa, whoa.
Where are the cherries?
Nice, nice, and nice.
Look at them.
One of these numbers is not blind.
Yeah!
Cherry, cherry, cherry, cherry, cherry, cherry, cherry!
Look how much we're getting!
Yippee!
Deposit your coins!
Okay!
We have many more.
We have a good head start now!
Oh!
Okay, cool.
One checky!
Uh, I'm gonna hold on to this.
Wait, let's see.
Cherry!
What?
Uh-oh.
Well, we have to make the decision.
Cherries versus lemons.
Wait!
Cherries versus Leavitts!
Wait, what do we have here?
Because I think the only way that...
What is this?
Okay.
The only way...
The only way we can...
I've kept the extra money, so just in case I wanted to restock.
The only way we could survive, though, is making the cherries more expensive, you guys!
more it's the only way it's the only way i do have oh i only have one slot left oh it's oh because of the
patterns multiplier plus one that could be good oh i wait i can't afford it i could i could give it i could put the book away again okay what i'm gonna do is go for the cherry
Next round, I guess that's true.
Play one round, yeah.
We'll play one round.
And then I could re-roll after if I wanted to.
Sapphire Eagle!
I got my main gear flash on Tuesday and some of the B-Day merch.
Thank you!
Sadly, I haven't been able to stop by recently, but I've been busy finishing college!
You got this!
I might graduate real soon.
Hope your luck is good today.
Thank you!
Learn lots.
Okay.
Alright.
I mean, we're not doing so poorly right now.
So, we'll do the one round.
And then we will...
Grab the stonks.
So much!
Oh!
Oh.
I thought I had a pattern there, no.
It's always the same amount, though.
Nice!
Wait, this is so awesome.
It's not going to be super sustainable forever, but it's pretty great right now.
Oh, so many Terry!
Yawa!
Nice!
Oh, it's the cat adding the entrance.
Okay, okay.
So now I can buy...
Ew.
And we have a...
Yeah, we have two.
Okay.
Wait.
It will tell me, right?
I don't remember when it stops.
Oh, it stops telling me after...
I get this, right?
Okay, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Okay, okay, okay, okay.
Okay, and this also...
It had, like, a special thing.
Patterns, multiplier, plus one.
So, that's exciting.
Maybe...
Eight ticket bonus.
What if we...
No, it's okay, I think.
Big fat cat!
Wait, what was
the...
Oh, wow!
Wow, the money is going kind of insane now.
Okay.
I forgot I've been meaning to ask Can I like leave Even if I'm mid like round
Many lemons Oh yeah Oh you can't Okay that's what I thought
Yubi Holy...
Money!
Chonky cat.
Look at that fat cat.
Whenever seven plus patterns trigger during a spin you earn money equal to double your current interest!
Let's hope we get this guy.
Should I...
I want to almost...
I almost want to like restock, but we only have one round.
How much?
I get four tickets if I sell early.
Hmm.
What do you guys think?
You can get it if you restock, but it's not guaranteed.
I do need tickets.
Well, yes.
But also, what I have right now is not so bad.
Okay.
I'm gonna
restock.
I restock if I'm about to deposit?
I've never tried to leave before.
But then at the same time,
Look at the golden lemon!
What does it... If I click on this, you could spoil.
If I click on this, don't spoil what happens, but if I click on this, will it make it so that i can't open a drawer
do it try it okay i'll try that's not the right key okay that's all i needed to hear you want to keep playing yeah yeah yeah i like your winter mentality go on okay there's no bones in here lame all right we got the cat food which is two spins plus that's pretty good that's pretty good pretty good and let's see what you have to say too more cherries more cherries more cherries more cherries oh my diary that's right you're right thank you for reminding me was there something else in there what is this where did that come from
add the gambler trait gain one free restock every deadline to a random Lucky charm.
I think I'm still going to go with the cherries.
I think I'll still go with the cherries, though.
You do you.
Cherry, cherry, cherry, cherry, cherry, cherry.
Do I get the extra spins?
Cherry, cherry, boy, cherry, cherry, girl.
That is a song from aka 48 if you were wondering what i was singing
look to the left of the shop
what this i've already looked at this and the toilet i've already done the toilet is there anything else i can do maybe i should do the cat food
spins pair well with the mushroom true oh my gosh wait you're so right i was thinking of the hand but the mushroom is That's huge!
Okay, I think we're good to go.
Let's go gambling.
What's, what?
You really don't know when to stop!
I know.
More cherries!
Cherry, cherry, cherry, cherry, cherry, cherry, cherry!
Cherry!
Yay!
Oh, so close.
I really need to get the cherry, the golden cherry, though, I think.
I think I need...
The final speed.
I think we'll be okay.
It's just the first round.
Okay.
That was so sad!
Ah,
so close.
Yeah, it's the catfoods farm!
Look, we almost made it back.
It's the catfoods farm!
We're all shot, but I have no...
Well, I guess I could try for the golden cherry.
I need the golden cherry.
I need the cherries to be, like, way more...
Hmm.
I could!
Yeah, we have two more turns.
We're okay.
We're okay for sure.
I could get eight tickets.
That'd be crazy.
They're only worth two.
I know!
We need to increase their value somehow.
Well, well, it's only manifest, though.
Clover voucher.
Free money?
The cherry, or the mushroom increases it, the more you get...
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
I don't know what I would get.
Probably the D4, maybe, to get rid of...
that let me store it let me store that and then we can get that d4 is good yeah but what else do i get rid of maybe the cat food i'm not gonna sell the d4 the chamsa no no this thing this thing has saved my booty
stonks can go in the drawer now i know you're trolling
It's sell the interest, you guys are crazy.
I'm gonna put this in the...
I'm gonna put the food in my drawer.
And then we'll buy this and see how we go.
See how we go, see how we go.
We're fine anyway, so...
Okay.
Looking real nice.
So close.
Yeah, baby!
Evil!
That's so evil!
Wow!
Ah!
I almost want to just...
Can't decide.
I'm being indecisive.
Um...
Do I want the four tickets?
I already re-rolled.
What do you mean, re-roll once?
I re-rolled before.
Tickets to fix our build.
What's wrong with our build?
What are you talking about?
Fix the build.
I got a golden cherry.
Da da da da da da da da da da da da.
And Chris.
Interest?
What?
Oh yeah, that's right.
Oh, this is hard!
This is hard!
I guess I could get rid of this now.
We could get rid of it.
But this like... I don't want to get rid of the mushroom because it's the...
Well, this would also be a way to increase the value.
You know what I mean?
But...
Uh...
You like the coin?
I like the coin I feel...
I like the extra spin that it gives.
Because sometimes if it gives a last spin...
Then it triggers the hand as well.
We need to have the mushroom with the golden cherry.
You think it'll be enough if we don't have the mushroom?
I mean, I guess I don't have as many spins because I got rid of the cat food, so...
Patrick, thank you so much for the super chat, thank you!
I think, though, at the very least I should get the cherry.
The fat guy?
Plus 3% chance for the ticket modifier to be applied to any shimbo.
Raises by 1% every time you buy a lucky charm.
Ticket modifier, scoring a symbol with the modifier earns you one ticket.
Well, let me just get the cherry for now.
This stream has recharged my Mentonium reserves.
Where are they, lol?
I've been streaming.
But thank you.
I guess I haven't made it to late game enough to know when tickets become so useful, you know.
is just like get more tickets get more tickets don't be low on tickets but i'm like oh i guess for this when you need to reroll huh i suppose when you're on the phone and you need or you need more stuff there and everything uh maybe well i'm i'm not gonna do the other round we're pretty we're pretty good i think so okay
re-rolling in some items cost a lot more tickets oh yeah yeah yeah
I'm gonna I'm gonna deposit we will try golden cherry next round if I want to start uh
I'm also I am reconsidering I don't know yet I don't know I don't know.
We'll figure it out.
Oh, scary, scary, scary!
Chonky cat!
Also, the briefcase.
Increases charm space!
Oh my gosh, huge, huge, huge!
We were hoping for this.
Nice!
Oh, got something new?
Property certificate.
Make space for two more lucky charms!
Should I...
So the Chonky Cat.
I could get both.
I could get the briefcase and the Chonky Cat.
I'm gonna hold off on the briefcase.
Just in case.
Might not need it, you know.
Yeah!
Wait, what is it?
Wait, where'd he go?
Oh, there he is.
whatever seven plus patterns trigger during a spin you earn money equal to double your current interest okay all right okay cat build suddenly okay okay okay briefcase is good for interest that's true oh yeah let me thank you for reminding me let me put my interest away
okay okay okay okay okay i mean like oh that is true that is true Because then we would have way more interest, right?
You're right.
You're right!
Let's get it.
You are now interest build.
I'm...
Yeah, I guess you're right.
Build, build.
Yeah.
The interest will save us.
Let's go gambling.
But I need...
I need...
Still to rely on cherries?
Because basically...
So...
Because with the cat, we need the seven, you know what I mean?
We need like the patterns of seven or higher to unlock Lucky Cat.
Which means we need still things that...
That will trigger more often, you know what I mean?
Like this.
Oh, I got something new!
Good amount.
So we're still a little bit...
reliance on the cherries it doesn't matter their amount so much but i don't think that was a cat you guys wow
that was a lot of money what did we get personal trainer plus 25 chance for the repetition modifier to be applied to any symbol decreased by 5% at the end of every round 25% Discard has...
Wait, scoring a symbol with this modifier re-triggers patterns containing...
Interesting, interesting.
What do I have in here?
Oh, the cat food.
And then this is the book.
Yes, yes, yes.
I think I'm gonna go for it so I can get more tickets.
What's the value of our cherries?
44!
What?
Rewel the shop.
So true!
Wow.
Bell.
Patterns.
They're kind of lame.
Pentacle.
Symbols multiplier plus one.
This bonus grows by whenever five plus patterns triggers during a spell.
Is it good for our build though?
Oh, it's permanent.
Oh, okay.
I'm trying to think of what we can start actually like.
I still think the hand is good because it increases our luck so much by the end that we could, like, trigger not just a jackpot, but kind of like how we got that one clover where it did the seven pattern.
Yeah, mushroom maybe.
Oh, I think a mushroom is time to go.
I think the mushroom is time to go.
You did your job.
Good job.
Good job, mushroom.
Yeah, because now we're actually really reliant.
Honestly, even the golden cherry.
Even though I just got it.
Because if we're doing more interest stuff now, We need cherry added, but we don't need the cherry number so much, you know?
Like the amount of it, I guess.
Golden cherries for scaling.
Does it?
Oh, it does, doesn't it?
Yeah.
Okay, it does.
Never mind.
You're right.
Okay.
Never mind.
Just kidding.
You're right.
I'm thinking about everything else for now.
Gumba gotta go.
Goomba gotta go.
Did I...
Okay.
I was wondering if I...
I guess it wasn't ringing, so...
Um...
Plus...
Symbols Multiplier.
Plus one.
I'll try it.
I'll get it.
And then I'm gonna get the eight tickets.
Or wait, oh, if I wanna start scaling it.
One more?
You guys are saying re-roll shot, but like, I have no tickets.
There's no point for me to re-roll.
There's no point.
I'll do one more.
Let's go.
Yippee!
Chonky cat.
What the?
Zombie duck.
I got mailed.
Oh, so...
Oh, it did!
Oh, it did trigger!
Yeah, baby!
Oh, girl!
Thank you so much for the brutal wreck!
Hello!
Hello, everybody!
We're making money!
We're gambling!
If you've never played this game, it's so fun, girl.
We're back.
Thank you for the five gifted, donkey.
Thank you for the gifted!
Thank you, the champion.
Thank you so much for the gifted!
Okay.
Oh, I do have another spin.
Lucky, lucky, lucky, lucky.
Oh, wait.
I feel like that...
Wait, I feel like I had more cherries, and then I...
Murphy, thank you for the five gifted!
Naughty dealer Plus 5% chance for the token modifier To be applied to any symbol Raises by 1% Every time you trigger 5 plus patterns During a spin Come on, thank you for the buy Thank you, thank you Thank you, thank you Thank you Thank you Oh Wait, we need this guy.
Wait, this...
Wait.
You fell into the clover pit, too, huh?
Oh, yeah.
Wait.
Re-roll for him.
One more?
Well, I need...
Tickets anyway, so I'm going to...
I'm gonna just...
and the...
One million?
Oh, thank you so much for the thank you, the thank you!
Oh, we got the little guy!
Double the value of lemons and cherries!
I
love a cherry!
No wonder you can't survive on drinks.
I need supplements!
Didn't use the book.
It's okay.
I want to spin first.
Let's go.
Unlucky?
I always know when they're gonna do the 6-6, if I'm gonna get like a 6 because it starts going real slow.
Yeah, Terry, Terry, Terry, Terry, Terry, Terry, Terry, Terry, Terry, Terry, Terry!
Why is it showing up?
more often now.
Huh?
Why is this?
Why?
That's the second time.
Oh, my gosh, I'm wood.
I love how many items are in this game.
It's kind of insane.
Nice.
Lucky hand!
Oh!
Oh my god Wait, I've already met
My gosh Wood Plus 35% chance for any cherry Wait, wait, wait Wait, this was made for my Build!
Wait, this was Wait, oh my god Wait, wait This was made for my build, you guys!
This was made for my build!
Oh my god, oh my god, oh my god!
Oh my god!
Everything's coming up, cherries!
Let's just re-roll.
Cherry.
Free?
Roll.
Bro!
Fruits basket.
Oh!
I said fruits basket.
Like the anime.
What would I get rid of?
I don't know what I would get rid of even though.
Coin?
Yeah, we could probably get rid of the coin.
Got my plushie today!
I can't wait to soak it in milk and throw it against the wall!
It's a limited item.
It does?
Oh, you're right, you're right.
It does.
Oh, no.
I'm gonna... Okay, I'm gonna sell our cat food for now.
Oh, wait.
I forgot I have this book, too.
I'm gonna...
I'm gonna sell the cat food because we don't have the, what's it called anymore?
The, uh...
Oh, what's it called?
Mushroom.
Yeah.
So, and then I'm gonna...
So, I'm gonna...
Throw away.
And then I'm going to...
Store our coin.
And then I'm going to try the fruit basket.
I need wood!
That's the goal.
Wood is the goal.
Eye on the...
I...
Oh my god!
Eye on the wood!
Please!
Let me live!
Oh my god.
Ah, not the...
Wait, no.
Was
it, it was like not lucky and not...
Oh my god.
No, let me just do that real quick.
Naughty dealer is good.
But I...
Ah, but the one!
Ditch the hand for the dealer.
You're- you're- I think you're so right actually.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Goodbye hand.
I'm just gonna go with that.
And I think I'm gonna depart...
Well...
Should I decide if I need to deposit for...
For more tickets or not?
Save the ink.
What do I have in here again?
Oh yeah, my coin.
Well...
I guess we could keep it in the drawer, huh?
I guess we could keep it in the drawer, and then if we ever need it, we just swap it out, right?
Yeah.
What's in here?
The book?
I'm gonna...
I don't want to get rid of the book, but I think I shall get rid of the book.
Or...
The coin, what do you do again?
Oh, wait, sorry.
One extra spin...
Oh, triggers randomly.
I mean, it's 10%, but it's, I feel like it triggered pretty often, but I think it's, yeah, throw away.
Equip it from the drawer when you lose.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
It did crazy for 10%.
That's what I'm saying.
That's what I'm saying, but yeah.
I think we need the assurance.
You reach the lucky charms limit.
Oh, I need two space.
Oh!
Ah!
Okay.
Aw, man.
Well...
Oh, I almost...
Put it in drawer.
Why?
Equip.
Okay.
And I'm gonna re-roll.
The hand's like, you can't get rid of me.
The book is like, you can't get rid of me!
The purse is pretty good.
And it's...
Okay, how about this?
It decreases by 3%.
We put...
Away the...
The D4.
For the purse.
I know the book has interest too There was like please please I'll be better I'll be better But um We put away the D4 for the purse And then once the purse depletes we try to get the wood You know
I think
That could be our goal Our strategy for right now Alright I'm gonna put away so I can get more Coins We need the wood We need the wood And there's wood!
Okay.
And there's wood.
There's none.
Cherries?
Uh-oh.
Speculative trait.
Ah!
Wait, this actually helps!
Thank you!
Bring your interest to 30% or more.
What's a D4?
It's a dice, right?
The cat!
The cat.
Now the hand is glowing.
Patterns multiplier.
Yeah.
Let's, let's, um, oh, um.
Deposit one million coins.
Not an addiction.
Okay.
All right.
Let's go gambling.
Oh, I forgot the fruit basket is also gonna...
Deplete.
Stop it.
Don't do that.
Holy...
Wait, how did I...
Because of the interest multiplier!
Oh, my dealer...
dealer duck.
Stop it!
It's only supposed to be 1.5!
Yeah!
Thank you!
Oh my...
Gosh!
Let's spin.
Or not spin.
Restock?
Oh!
It's
at 12% This still has five rounds left.
The wood is here, everybody.
Also, it's only one ticket.
Oh, that I need more.
Oh, she's got wood!
Sell the golden cherry.
I don't know, though.
Because the golden cherry, it stacks, no?
Like, it scales?
Yeah, we want to keep the golden cherry.
Yeah.
Get rid of the purse.
Yeah, I think we get rid of the purse.
Because...
The fruit...
So basically, if this has the modifier and it doubles, like that's huge.
Yeah, Fruit Basket has crazy value on those five uses still.
I agree, I agree.
No, you can't buy a drawer.
What's in here anyway?
Oh, my D4.
And the Ankh.
Purse will just be useless later.
Yeah, I know, yeah, so...
I think I'll get rid of the purse.
Golden Cherry only adds basic value per trigger.
Am I crazy?
Everyone was telling me it stacks, though.
I'm...
I get so many mixed messages.
I think maybe I just don't understand what it does, like, exactly.
So...
Because we got to 264 because it's been adding the plus 2 every time, no?
We could always get another golden cherry eventually.
Not good late game.
Oh.
So if we sold this and then...
You
want multipliers, not addition.
I guess that's fair.
I don't know.
The only thing is because the purse has depleting value.
I'm like, why do I keep it?
Why would I get rid of...
I mean, I'm sure something else might come along if I still sell the cherry and this is gone.
But...
I think I...
I...
I
could get another purse.
Yeah, that's so true.
I'm gonna...
Okay.
I'll get rid of the cherry until the purse is kind of similar to how I was like I'll keep the purse until we get the wood.
We'll keep...
Maybe the purse will stay until we get another cherry or something like that.
You get 20k from cherries and 2m from cats.
The value of cherries isn't going to scale higher than interest.
I guess that's fair, too.
I guess that's fair.
fair too.
Okay, fine.
Goodbye, Cherry.
We're wood people now.
I must... Oh my God!
Do you see that amount?
Wait.
I want to see... I want to see... I want to see it happen.
Let's go.
Oh!
I need another fruit.
I need
another fruit basket.
Oh my god!
The- the wood is already paying off!
The wood!
Woohoo!
I got an achievement for that event.
Which was like, get 15...
Oh.
Oh my god!
Don't do...
Don't do this to me!
Oh my god!
Did we lose our...
No.
How many... How many do you have left?
Four left, okay.
I think I'm just gonna...
Is that 144 million?
Wait, before we do that, let's see what we got too.
Oh...
Lucky times at the store are discounted by two.
What's the clicker?
This guy?
Oh, oh, oh, wait!
Wouldn't that replace the fruit basket?
If, uh,
pretty much.
If we got it?
And they stack!
What's that?
What's this guy do?
The Pentacle do again.
Oh, symbols multiplier plus 13.
This bonus grows by one whenever...
Ah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
That's pretty huge.
Could be big.
Pentacle is not as good as Retro, girl.
I think so, too.
Sell the D4.
I think honestly the D4 is kind of...
We don't need it anymore.
If we wanted to get the clicker, we could like...
We could put the pentacle in the drawer or something.
That's what I think I'll do.
Oh!
I forgot to do the discount.
Oopsie.
But I'll still go with three, yeah.
That's what I was thinking, anyway.
Okay.
Let's try this out.
Let's see how...
Oh, wait.
Just kidding.
Let's...
Okay.
Our interest is 13 million, so we might be okay.
Let's go gambling.
Wait,
but it's only like plus 500.
Wait.
Why is it so low?
What
is the plus 528 then?
What am I seeing?
I'm speechless.
I'm just listening to the numbers happening.
I'm just listening to dollar sign go up.
Why is it so low?
She says, the greed sickens me.
Her greed.
It sickens me!
Thank you for my ticket.
Oh my guys!
Guys, guys!
I think you broke it.
I mean...
We don't know quite yet.
Thank you so much for the 50!
We don't know.
We don't know quite yet.
I still want to get my...
Honestly, I want to give more, like, than 50% for charity.
Money go up!
What's in the shop?
I'll reroll just for fun.
Where is this one?
Last three deadlines and discard this trolley.
The end of each deadline gives us many...
Oh, the many...
Tickets.
Yeah.
Wee.
Build a surplus because the money requirements are gonna start going be an expo.
Yeah, I know exactly.
Oh, eight plus.
Oh yeah, we get plus two now.
That's right.
Let's go.
Let's go gambling!
How
many more do I have on my fruit basket?
We'll check.
Two rounds left.
I want to secure a new one, honestly.
I'm gonna hear the sound of my dreams.
Oh my god!
Jackpot would be insane right now.
I don't think my luck is high enough.
Unfortunately.
Almost at a billion!
Let's see.
Should I just...
I think I'll just end around here.
Well, I have 11 tickets, but maybe we'll want to reroll, so I'm going to end here, I think.
Yeah.
It's okay.
It's okay, guys.
Holy moly!
So much!
Oh my gosh.
Oh my gosh!
Wait.
Double jackpot's value.
Wait, what else do we have?
Oops.
Make space for two more lucky times!
That's kind of huge, actually.
Wait, so it...
Wait, it takes up space but then gives more space?
Wait.
I have to make space for the space.
I have to make space for more space.
So it's plus one.
Okay, okay, okay.
The basket's about to go.
True.
Oh, it has two rounds left.
Wait, what about this one?
Oh, oh, wait.
The purse.
There we go.
Oh, is that three?
Oh, we can get rid of the purse.
Oh.
Goodbye, goodbye, goodbye purse.
Oh, what is that?
Cardboard house.
Snake.
Make space for one more lucky time.
This charm will not show up again after usage.
Oh, and it doesn't take up space!
Okay, we gotta get the cardboard house.
Okay.
I wonder, though, what's your...
I guess we'll put the Pentacle back up because I quit.
Because we can.
Okay.
Oh, all right.
And I think for the phone, I'm gonna...
Re...
Roll.
What, the other charms?
Ew, ew, it's not really anything that I need.
I'm gonna reroll.
Wait!
Maybe the obsessive trait?
Obsessive would probably be good.
Does it...
To a random lucky charm.
So...
Does it...
Does it trigger to whatever it's...
I'm guessing it triggers to whatever it is.
So...
so it's useless wait
wait it's wait it's good?
Wait how
whatever goes last spin oh so it doesn't matter
okay it's passive okay I was what I was trying to say is I didn't know if it triggered like if it was on the cat if it triggered the cat again or something but it's the last Oh!
Yippee!
Okay.
I'm gonna deposit now.
What I'm gonna do probably this time is all three...
I don't know.
Do I want the more...
Well, regardless, I don't have enough, so...
Buy a charm.
Well, what... I don't have... I'm not gonna buy a charm.
What are you talking about?
I know I have one more charm space, but I'm not gonna just buy one.
What are you guys talking about?
You guys are silly.
Okay, I'm gonna deposit this.
Okay, we need quite a bit, but deposit one billion coins!
Yippee!
Okay.
Let's go.
Guys, the thing in the drawer, I'm not, I don't need to take it out, it's okay.
Did I, wait, did I already reach it or?
Oh wow, a rare spin where I got nothing.
13 billion, okay, thank you.
Wow, oh wow, that's so lame!
Getting nothing is so lame.
200.
I need more fruit basket.
Wait, what if I had double fruit basket?
What if I got another one and then I double?
You know?
204.
Are you, are you...
Are you screwing with me right now?
Game!
Don't... don't mess with me.
Ah!
It's not greed, it's desperation.
Oh yeah, let me deposit.
Thank you.
I think I'm gonna have to go the other two rounds, honestly.
I think I'm gonna have to go.
The other two rounds.
What I'll do is after this, I could reroll.
and then um because I think the fruit basket will be done after this so we will have two extra slots if we get lucky with a re-roll you know
we're not getting such a good I mean we are but like at the same time you know I don't feel confident I don't feel confident though wait I already made quota oh Oh,
oh, oh, oh, oh, oh,
oh.
Yippee!
Oh, no, my fruit!
My fruit, my fruit.
Wait.
Oh, yeah.
Okay, I'm gonna do one re-roll.
Well, I don't need to I don't need to go again, but it would be maybe good to do it Do I save up more money or do I I'm gonna roll And then I'm gonna do another round Yeah
Do these?
These don't stack though, right?
The trainers Like the modifiers, I guess?
I don't think I will do the cat food.
I think I will do the personal trainer.
Modifiers do not stack.
It will overlap.
But it'll...
Well...
Yeah.
No, I get what you mean.
Oh, but it's temporary.
I forgot about this.
No.
I have two I have two slots I think I'm still going to go with the personal trainer though I think it's I think having the repetition modifiers honestly good enough
by both I don't have enough I don't have enough tickets
I'm a celebrity everything.
Ah, yeah.
We'll go with the personal trainer.
And then, I'm going to do another round, but we're going to deposit first.
More interest, more interest.
Oh, yeah.
Oh, well.
That's fine.
Let's go gambling.
Hoi!
10 Billy in your pocket.
Is that 10 Billy in your pocket or are you just happy to see me?
Maybe good.
Oh no.
Oh, thank goodness.
I think it's good that I did another round.
Unless I lose it all.
Yeah.
Deposit your coins now!
I have enough.
Don't you worry.
I've got enough.
Don't you worry, your pretty little head.
We've reached the E!
E, E, E, E.
And I get plus four!
So honestly, not so bad.
E, E, E, E!
What do we got here?
Avid.
I got the D4 back.
Couldn't do that.
Double the value of lemons and cherries!
I mean...
I wish I got adds more chance of getting cherries.
Not this late.
Honestly, I was thinking that.
I wish that's why I was like...
Ha!
But the tickets?
Nah, we're interest people now.
What do I have here again?
Wonder if I should get the D4.
I think I'll get the tickets, yeah.
I see cherry symbol and I get excited.
Buy the D4.
Is it worth so much to get it?
I mean, I guess so that you can have a pattern.
I guess so.
You could D4 into a jackpot if I'm so lucky.
I need more luck.
If I am so lucky.
How much even is this that it's requesting of me?
Look at this!
Almost every single thing!
It's a lot of money, isn't it?
It saved the run.
Not the run.
Saved the spin.
I
need more chances to get cherries.
I couldn't you be a cherry.
More cherry, cherry, cherry, more cherry, cherry, more cherry, cherry, cherry, cherry.
Are we doing it in the fruit basket?
Again, again, again!
Oh, you... I can't... I
was...
So stinking close!
I think it
liked that.
I think the But she liked that.
Like, I feel like I'm edging it or something.
I saw a certain rock princess hit 1033.
I bet you...
But you bet what?
Oh
my gosh, she's asking for so much.
Uh...
Oh, ah!
Okay.
We keep going.
Hold on.
I'm...
Thank you.
If only this were a jackpot!
I think we got robbed.
It was no money.
Now I got robbed!
Oh my gosh!
That was so scary!
Lucky 666 ever, I know!
I need to go get some more water soon.
We hit E!
Wait, we might make it!
I think we'll make it!
Maybe.
No, no, no, go!
Hey!
Why aren't you doing your job?
Huh?
Oh, now you choose.
Imagine if we last it out.
That's the thrill, baby!
That's the thrill!
Do you guys think I should spin?
Wait, what are you at?
But this is...
I kind of want the plus four tickets though.
Wait, what am I...
Oh, I see, I see.
Oh, okay.
So we're not quite yet.
Wait, what?
Am I not over?
I don't know how E works.
I couldn't make it?
Oh, yikes.
Ugh.
If I got a jackpot, maybe.
Might be good time for Ankh.
You were so right.
I'm gonna move.
I'm gonna take...
Which one do I take, though?
You're right.
This is a good time for Ankh.
Onk time, onk time.
D4 is slacking?
I thought so too, honestly.
But we'll keep it just because it could come in handy.
We'll see.
It could come in handy.
This is too scary.
I need water.
I'll be right back.
Paz has joined us.
I didn't realize she snuck in.
Hey!
What are you doing, silly girl?
Okay!
I'm scared!
Oh, God!
Oh, fruit basket!
Ah!
We gotta eat!
We got
more E!
E!
We might, the interest might help us.
But we're also losing at the same time because of the personal trainer.
Oh, I got a shoe.
The personal trainer is also depleting, you know?
Oh!
D4 kind of came in clutch there.
Babe babe.
Wait.
Are you gonna get mad at me?
Don't get mad at me.
Come on.
Come on, buddy.
We're buddies, no?
We're buddies, right?
Come on, I just need a little bit more time!
Well, well, what?
Okay, I have a question if anybody has tried this.
If you...
What's the word?
If you were like, if it was doing the boop, boop, boop, boop, you know, and it was still in here, do you...
Are you able to switch it out or does it like not let you?
You can very quickly switch things around.
Oh, that's kind of exciting.
That's kind of really exciting.
Okay, guys.
Oh, my gosh.
It's so expensive to reroll.
Wait, what was my mail?
I got the shoe.
Plus 20% chance for any cherry to have a ticket modifier.
Scoring a symbol with this modifier earns you one ticket.
Okay.
I can reroll.
It's just...
I don't think I should.
But we have two more...
We have two more rounds now, so...
Do it after you're safe.
I think so, too.
I don't like the E.
It confuses me.
Okay.
Interest, the interest might save us, honestly.
I think it will save us.
Oh!
That was so close!
What, are you mad that you came in here?
She's looking at me with such disdain.
I got a mega cat.
Wait, this is what I need, right?
Oh my gosh, don't do that to me!
Buff cat.
I want the buff cat.
Oh.
Okay, I think now we actually have enough.
Yay!
Oh.
Stop jinxing it.
Isn't that part of the thrill?
No spans out.
Oh, he's gone!
He's gone, he's gone, he's gone.
Swole cat.
Whenever 15 plus patterns trigger during a spin you earn money equal to four times your current interest.
15 patterns though, I would need The most cherry build ever.
I will re-roll once because also we have two slots, so.
First, free money.
And then, fruit the basket.
Do I go for it?
Well, I have 12.
tickets, I mean.
Should we?
Always roll.
Okay!
Oh,
my pentacle!
I forgot about it.
Oopsie!
What was I gonna say?
Oh my gosh.
Thank you!
Oh my god, please!
Don't leave me with nothing!
We need more cherries.
Cherries, cherries, we need more cherries!
Okay!
Okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay.
Okay, okay, okay, okay.
17!
I don't know how much this is at all.
What if we get cherries?
Lemons manifest more often.
A gazillion?
Hold on.
One second, more in second.
What do we have here?
Oh!
I got the cardboard box!
That's so...
But, I mean, I'm gonna get it.
Yeah.
And then I can equip this as well.
So I don't forget, you know.
Um...
Yahoo!
wondering if i should like have something like a green pepper you know just kind of on hand get the pepper why not that's what i'm thinking
whoa what's that red shiny rock grants luck plus four for the next spin oh okay
yeah and we'll get a freebie free free re-roll which is good um i think I think next I'll be able to get rid of the pentacle, probably.
But we'll have it just for now, because why not?
And then for this, what do we want to add it to?
Wait.
I guess the obsessive.
I guess obsessive.
Stop projecting your ideas onto reality.
What did it add to?
Oh, Mr. Dilla.
Hide the fruit first.
Ah, it's okay.
It didn't get there.
Oopsie.
Um.
Okie dokie.
Deposit.
Alright, let's go.
Oh.
Let's go gambling.
It's kind of interesting that I have nothing right now that is for, uh, with a button, you know?
Oh!
Nothing with a button right now though.
Are you winning son?
Oh, I almost lost.
Oh,
so lame.
Come on.
Never stop projecting game announcements into reality.
How can you guys read these numbers?
I can't tell at all what I have...
What I'm getting anymore.
I have no idea!
Again!
He means nothing to me.
I don't understand it at all.
D4 came in clutch here.
Oh, it's starting to get a little crazy.
Oh, oh, oh, you're okay.
Why is it do that sometimes?
We get a little worked up, huh?
Mr. Machine.
The numbers, what do they mean?
Thank you!
You're holding over 500 trillion.
Really?
But what do I...
What do I need?
I can't read.
I don't know.
Take the first number, add zero, the same amount after the E number.
Huh?
What?
You need a lot more.
Yeah, I think so.
Uh.
Should I?
Oh, wait.
I don't think I can roll.
Uh-oh.
Uh-oh, we're in trouble.
Oh my gosh, I could only deposit once.
Oh, no.
Oh, no, we're in trouble.
Let's go get- Oh, no, we're in trouble!
Team!
It means- oh, you guys can try to explain it, but I think I'm just dumb.
Maybe we'll get a jackpot from the pepper.
We shall hope, we shall pray.
That's not a jackpot.
One E number to go up.
Yeah, yeah, that's what I figured.
D4 sleeping on the job.
I know!
I need my pepper to work too.
I need you to work, please.
I need more luck.
I need more luck, please.
Oh, this
is so bad.
This is so bad.
Help!
Guys, this is just how the slots go.
You know, sometimes the slots, I like to describe them as a beautiful one.
and all just spinning you round and round in circles and sometimes you score and most times you don't but I love women I love women in their cherries hey
mr.
dealer ma'am why aren't you working huh
Why aren't you working?
Wait, cancel?
Oh, this modifier, that's right.
Jackpot!
Just kidding!
I think the pepper also screwed me over.
This is a thing you just said.
Yeah?
Can you imagine?
Jackpot!
Wait.
That's not it.
That's a lot of zeros.
Ah!
One jackpot saves the run.
Guys, this is the last round.
It's over.
Unless we get jackpot.
Okay, I'm going to close my eyes.
I'm not going to look.
I'm just going to pull the trigger.
Hold on.
I'm going to let my cat out.
going crazy I'm
gonna pull it I'm gonna pull it I'm gonna pull the trigger and then I'm gonna make myself a nice bowl of macaroni and cheese in heaven
Good run, everybody.
Good run, good run, good run, good run.
I was struggling at the beginning of the stream, but...
We...
The challenge is increasing!
What does that mean?
Welcome back.
Time to gamble.
You already know how it works?
Come on.
Wait, let's see what we got.
Oh!
That's my song!
Whoa, Bilatro.
Bilatro.
By the way, try earning a lot of coins.
I might have a deal for you.
I was wondering what the claw was up there!
Mortis.
Thank you for the silver chat.
Thank you!
Oh my gosh, cardboard house!
wait this is kind of like awesome i guess not in the beginning but let's see what we got d6 screw you i don't want disc a disc b disc c ace of cards ace of clubs ace of diamonds ace of spades
oh oh okay
and the discs oh oh Every seven spins plus seven...
Lock!
For seven spins, patterns will repeat one more time.
Where's the D6?
Yeah, there.
Restock the store for free at the end of every round.
Unlockable by opening two drawers and dying.
I mean...
I did that.
Dying five times.
One trick pony.
One jackpot next round at the slot machine?
I could have used you.
Okie dokie.
I think that was pretty good.
I think that was pretty good, you guys.
Good.
Thank you all for helping me out as well.
Oh, man.
Yeah, it's still locked.
I gotta die some more.
I don't...
I might play some more.
offline so i can like kind of um experiment with some things you know without having people yelling at me being like you picked the wrong thing and and all that fun stuff a lot of fun watching numbers go up very thank you good luck escaping the maze tomorrow yeah i will be on nimmy's channel tomorrow to try and explain the e thing with examples 10 is 1 e1 100 is 1 e2 1000 oh is 1 e3 goes up it adds another digit to the end oh okay that does help that does help that does help thank you inspect the toilet i already have i already inspected it i was drawing by your cute face in the thumbnail thank you welcome welcome but we're about to end the stream um tomorrow stream will not be uh wait oh my gosh i don't know how oh wait oh my gosh okay youtube back end changed everything and i was like how do i do redirects uh tomorrow's stream will not be on my channel it will be on nimmy nightmares channel um oh she's streaming right now is this a this isn't a members is it is she streaming normal
wait let me check nobody double check it will be on her channel though so i will be there oh yeah she's streaming normal okay then i will redirect you guys to nimmy and tomorrow's her birthday so please tell her a happy birthday either today or um we'll see you um it will be me phoebe and of nimmy of course obviously yeah i saw her get bonked by youtube i saw her was it the game that that fmv game um but uh uh i saw it i went to her stream and it said like uh this stream has been taken down due to policy something something thank you thank you so much for the peek thank you yeah we made it to the east um uh door go thank that and I was like is this what happens to me oh it was the game streaming conditions that's so sad it thought it was a movie I think is what she said that's weird though because I mean I know it was an FMV but like it shouldn't think it's a movie unless the game unless like the developers the publishers whatever have like super strict something on the game because
FMVs shouldn't alone oh my gosh i was watching saba play at dead of night i think it's what it's called and i've i've known about that game for a long time and i cannot play it that game stresses me the heck out so i oh my gosh i so i was watching her play it and i was like she's so brave the game has weird rules to put a disclaimer in your description ah thank you so much for the podcast thank you but yeah anyway um okay I will go now so YouTube AI so scary so scary thank you guys for your help today and thank you for watching and thank you for gambling with me all right so much fun uh big number go up up up to bigger number yeah oh it's so beat though everybody have a good day have a good night don't forget to wish Nimiya happy happy birthday uh uh tomorrow I'll see you on her channel And if I see you,
I'll see you Yeah!
Otavito!
Thank you, everybody!
Thank you, thank you, thank you, thank you!
Thank you, thank you!
Bye-bye!
Bye-bye, bye-bye!
Now I will thank you so much for the 20 years!
Thank you!
Bye-bye!